Today's video is sponsored by Ray Khan,
home of wireless earbud designs inspired by underdogs and big dreams.
Recon ebbed started around half the price of other premium wireless earbud
brands,
but they sound just as amazing as other top audio brands and they look pretty
cool too. Just check it out. These are the everyday [inaudible] earbuds,
super soft, super flexible to fit different air sizes,
and they will have a range of colors too. Um,
what I'd loving about them is the seamless Bluetooth pairing.
So I can easily listen to podcasts and audio books when I'm on the go. Now,
these everyday E 20 fives are good for around six hours of continuous playtime,
but this handy case doubles as a charger, and you can recharge up to four times.
What's your abs and abouts commuting at the gym or wherever life takes you.
So if you want a premium airbag at around half,
the price of other brands rake on is for you or for those that you love.
Ray Khan makes the perfect gift,
practical and stylish offering quality audio for work or play at home,
or even on the go now is the time to get the best prices of the year on
Rakeon's,
but you need to hurry because this offer is available for a limited time only go
to buy Ray con.com forward slash visual politic to get 20% off your order.
[Inaudible].
If there is one thing that characterizes the extreme East of Asia,
it has been the recent power struggle between different political and military
players, such as China, Russia, and the United States. And of course,
if there has ever been one country,
one nation of people that has always been in the midst of so much geopolitical
turbulence,
whether in the Soviet era or in the age of a rapidly modernizing China,
it has to be career
The people of Korea who have historically been forced to survive between the
influences of the Chinese empire and the expansionist aspirations of the
Japanese empire are today divided into two ideologically opposed countries,
each supported by rivaling superpowers with a lot of tension and enormous
distrust between them.
All of this has led to the two careers to make their armed forces a national
priority. Today, as you will know, North Korea, possesses nuclear weapons,
and relatively advanced ballistic missile technology,
as well as thousands and thousands of pieces of artillery for its part.
South Korea has one of the best technologically equipped armies in the world
with a very advanced air force and one of the most advanced anti-missile
protection systems in existence.
However, despite the fact that both careers are arms to the hilt,
the truth is that these days are new armed confrontation between the two seems
unlikely.
And unlike other cases where calm has been achieved through diplomatic means
today's tense.
Peace on the Korean peninsula is almost exclusively the results of military
deterrence, neither the Trump and Kim Jong urn summits in Singapore and Hanoi,
nor the meetings moon Jae in and Kim in Panmunjom and Pyongyang have served to
substantially improve things in Korea. The diplomatic route is simply frozen.
We are talking about a scenario in which the two main actors,
one of them in particular, of course, I'm talking about North Korea.
I run able to give up a shred of political diplomatic or military ground to the
other side.
The fact is that the United States has not found a way for Pyongyang to dispose
of its nuclear weapons. And of course,
North Korea cannot afford to give up its nuclear weapons because the survival of
the regime itself depends on them. And then despite its many attempts,
South Korea has been unable to promote reforms in the North that would allow for
the lifting of sanctions and economic cooperation.
So what is left to do faced with such a mess,
exactly military deterrence,
that is to be strong enough so that the other side does not even remotely
consider going down the path of an armed attack to achieve its goals and
friends. That is precisely what we are going to look at in this video. But no,
this time we are not going to tell you about the North Korean army.
I'm sure you've heard 1,001 things about it.
So this time we're going to talk about the much lesser known South Korean army,
which by various estimates is the sixth most powerful army in the world.
Listen up. Oh, by the way,
we wanted to let you know that we've launched a new history channel visual
Academy. I'll leave the link in the description.
It is totally different to this channel. And sadly,
there are no bald guys or Hawaiian shirts,
but if you want history presented to you in a fresh way,
I think you might like it. Let us know in the comments, what you think.
And I'll see you there.
The American shield.
Friends of visual politic the evolution of the South Korean military has been
almost as successful as the country's own economic miracle in just one decade.
It has gone from being little more than Pancho's Villa's army to one of the most
advanced in the world. As you can imagine, they did not get there on their own.
In this case, the United States played a key role.
[Inaudible].
After the end of the Korean war in 1954,
the defense of South Korea was technically left in the hands of the United
States, which commanded OpCon the acronym for operational control.
During the war, the South Koreans had used up all their military resources.
The exhaustion together with the shortage of modern equipment made it impossible
for the American power to withdraw completely,
which under the circumstances would have left the country unprotected and
vulnerable to bits, communist, neighbors, China, and North Korea.
So what they did was stay and train instruct and prepare the South Korean
army. In fact,
much of the design of the South Korean military structures was done by
replicating, or at least was clearly inspired by the model of the S.
Forces.
Not only gaps in order to compensate for North Korea's bolstering of arms,
the United States also deployed some of its most important strategic weapons in
South Korea. These included the dreaded nuclear weapons.
Late 1950s, the United States began moving numerous nuclear warheads into Korea.
They reached almost a thousand units by the mid 1960s. However,
as the cold war faded away on the one hand,
the relations between Washington and Beijing continued to improve on the other,
this powerful arsenal was gradually reduced. So that by 1991,
there were no more us nuclear warheads permanently deployed in South Korea.
And exactly the same thing happened with the deployment of us troops.
The number of which was gradually reduced, but of course,
all those years of South Korea being completely under the U S military umbrella
gave the country time to improve its military capabilities. For example,
president puck Chung,
he himself launched an ambitious program known as yell Ngoc in the
1970s to boost an indigenous military industry.
But it was not only a question of the quantity of weapons if they really wanted
to be self-sufficient in the military field and guarantee national security,
regardless of decisions made in Washington,
South Koreans needed state-of-the-art equipment,
rapid intervention capabilities,
and new structures adapted to the requirements of modern warfare.
And that is precisely what they did.
Not
change. Of course.
That the South Korean military has faced over the past 40 years has been to move
from being a virtually land-based force to one that is much more balanced in its
defense of the air and the sea as well. For this purpose,
three military reforms were implemented one in 2005,
another in 2011 and the last one in 2017 by current president moon Jae in
with these reforms,
the goal has been to substantially reduce the size of the army,
but at the same time to turn it into a much more fearsome force,
better equipped, better trained,
able to be deployed more efficiently and made up of better land sea and air
units achieving a total ratio of two to one.
To one.
Many of these reforms have been carried out or implemented to a large extent.
The OpCon the body that would have military control in times of war has not been
transferred and still remains under the direction of the United States.
And in fact,
the last of the three military reforms that of the current president moon called
defense reform,
2.0 is oriented to improve South Korea capacities against the North Korean
asymmetric war.
And also to finally achieving the transfer of the OpCon to South Korea in times
of war.
But the fact is that efforts so far have focused primarily on completing the
development of three key strategies against current North Korean threats,
the preventative kill chain system, the Korean air and missile defense,
K a M D,
and the Korea massive punishment and retaliation KMP are all three, by the way,
our combat strategies aimed at the Terrance and take notes because this is
something that South Koreans are taking very,
very seriously without going any further.
President moon's intention to achieve a 53% increase in military spending
between 2017 and 2023,
thus going from a budget of around $30 billion a year to one that exits
$50 billion. Now,
what exactly do all these changes imply in terms of armament? Well,
let's take a look.
The crown jewels.
We're talking about military equipment. We can say that South Korea has,
or is buying some of the best military equipment in the world.
And we're not just talking about, well, let's call it traditional equipment.
In addition to the approximately 2,500 tanks, 2,400 armored vehicles,
5,400 pieces of artillery,
or more than 150 modern fighters that make up the South Korean war inventory.
We must also add advanced equipment in missile defense and ballistic to
Terrance. And also during recent years,
the country has been negotiating the acquisition of fifth generation fighter.
We are.
For example,
about the American F 35 stealth fighter of which South Korea will have 80 units,
60 a version a and 20 a version B version, by the way,
which boasts vertical takeoff capability. In addition,
the Korean aerospace company,
Kai is developing its own fifth generation fighter jet.
Also very similar to the F 35 currently called K F X.
The intention of this program is that the capabilities of this aircraft will
greatly exceed those of the European Eurofighter or the French Dassault
Rafale for example,
Not just in the air where there is news.
The South Korean Navy is engaged in a program of building and acquiring new
submarines. That includes the development of a new indigenous class,
the Jang BOGO three class summary.
It is also incorporating destroyers equipped with the ages combat system and
light aircraft carriers from which it will be able to deploy at the F 35,
but undoubtedly,
the most insignificant military advances are taking place in the field of
missile defense.
It's Korea has already developed a low level missile umbrella using Patriot
missile batteries that make up a pack two system,
a system that South Korea seems certain to upgrade to pack three,
to make it much more accurate and responsive to short and medium range.
Missile attacks.
Three uses a two pulse solid rocket motor that increases the altitude and range
to defend against evolving threats so that the newer missile interceptors are
expected to be useful in thwarting. The North's new type of missile threats,
South Korean ministry of defense official on condition of anonymity.
Another high level anti-missile shield is also deployed the famous and
controversial us fart,
which aims to protect the country from Intercontinental or large missiles,
which fly at much higher altitudes.
But without a doubt to the most striking is South Korea's effort to become
independent and create a third anti-missile shield.
This time made himself to Rhea. And we are talking about Shalma too.
[Inaudible].
System uses the Russian intersection technology of its famous S 400,
wait a minute, Russian technology in South Korea. Yes,
the United States refuses to sell this type of technology to third parties,
even if they are such important allies.
So the South Koreans have had to turn to the Russians.
The missiles with this system are being developed by the South Korean company
league. Next one. And despite having a unit cost of $1.2 million,
the truth is that the South Korean system challenged the two aims to become one
of the cheapest anti-missile shields in the world.
It has even plans to be exported to other Southeast Asian countries.
And although it does not offer the same range as other anti-missile systems,
the idea of the South Korean authorities is to take advantage of its low cost to
deploy it throughout the country, fast, creating a real iron dome.
The system is capable of intercepting missiles up to 15 kilometers high and
within a 40 kilometer range where the battery,
The fact is that in this way,
South Korea will foreseeably have from 2021 onwards, not one,
not two but three anti-missile systems that will protect the country from North
Korean frets. However, a lot of people are wondering is all of this enough.
Well, that is the debate. And what is certain is that there is no consensus,
many military experts,
and even former South Korean ministers have gone so far as to call for going
further and developing nuclear weapons off their own once and for all,
but is it reasonable for South Korea to develop its own nuclear weapons?
Is it militarily possible? Is it politically and diplomatically possible?
Listen up.
A nuclear solution. Okay.
This may not sound familiar to many of you,
but South Korea's nuclear program is not something farfetched or even something
that hasn't already been tried. In fact, in the early 1970s,
despite the fact that there were already us nuclear warheads in Korea,
president puck, he launched an indigenous nuclear weapons development program,
the program, however, remained in the research phase.
And although it is believed that South Korea gained the knowledge necessary to
manufacture a nuclear weapon,
the truth is that no device was ever produced or tested there.
So why did the program stop?
Basically.
It was due to pressure from the United States, which was a game,
this nuclear proliferation in Korea from the beginning,
they finally managed to dissuade park from stopping the program and signing the
non-proliferation treaty in 1975.
However many analysts believe that South Korea conducted occasional experiments
over the next few years in secret.
And that today they would be capable of building a nuclear bomb in no more than
18 months, that would make it in fact, a de facto nuclear state,
a status it would share with countries like Japan.
And of course over the past few years,
especially after the latest North Korean nuclear tests in 2016 and 2017,
there have been numerous voices in South Korea calling for a return to the
indigenous nuclear weapons program. In fact, according to a September, 2017,
Gallup poll,
60% of South Koreans would support the development of their own nuclear weapons.
In addition,
South Korea is most nationalistic and conservative factions believe that they
can no longer depend on the United States for strategic defense.
As the Trump presidency has shown that either you are capable of defending
yourself, or you could have a Hong Kong.
Yeah.
Unlike other presidents,
Trump has been the least friendly by far to those who may be his best allies in
East Asia. Trump.
Ignites cost sharing dispute with South Korea VOA,
we lose four and a half billion dollars to defend a country that's rich as hell.
And probably doesn't like us too much. President Trump. Yes.
That's right.
Trump unleashed a whole diplomatic dispute with South Korea to get the country
to pay more money to the United States,
to offset the costs of troops stationed there.
And Trump did in fact manage to get another billion dollars out of president
moon. Something that he even brazenly scoffed at.
It was easier to get a billion dollars from South Korea than to get
$114 and 13 cents from a rent controlled apartment in Brooklyn, president Trump.
Of course,
given the hostility to South Korea demonstrated by Trump during his presidency.
Many wonder whether South Korea with the military and economic means it has,
should continue to depend on the Americans for its strategic defense.
And for this reason, nuclear weapons have returned to the debate.
Although president moon has already said,
this is not something that will happen during his presidency even.
So what do you think should South Korea guarantee its nuclear deterrence
capacity in the face of the North Korean threat and the latest us rampage after
rural North Korea already has nuclear weapons and has zero intention of getting
rid of them. So why not South Korea?
Wouldn't it be more practical to develop nuclear weapons of their own instead of
having nearly 25,000 us soldiers on the ground,
which generates high costs for both countries or on the contrary,
would this merely create a diplomatic problem and fuel the conflict with North
Korea? Anyway, these are not easy questions to answer,
but that's the way things stand on the Korean peninsula.
Leave us your opinions in the comments. And remember if you liked this video,
don't forget to give it a like and subscribe to our channel.
So you don't miss anything new. And of course,
don't forget to visit our new channel visual Academy.
If you want to learn more about politics and world affairs.
And here's some more of my lovely voice,
check out the reconsidered podcast where we don't do the thinking for you find
reconsider@wwwreconsideredmedia.com or on Apple or Google play or your favorite
podcast.